This edition of Scoutmasters podcast is brought to you by the folks of Conahoe Creek. out there
They know camping and they know scouts. They are scouts
And they know how to get you quick here at Green Crisis for all your camping adventures.
So go visit them at conahoecreakcom-
That's C-O-N-O-H-O-Creakcom.
And now the old scout master,
Ron Herrera, is the scout master of Troop 97 in Harbor Creek, Pennsylvania,
And he tells me they were out on a weekend camping trip and they were focusing on cooking
and the patrols were busy cooking for a couple of hours and they made a pretty elaborate dinner
As the adults watched quietly.
Well, you know, adults can't watch scouts cook quietly.
I mean, sometimes you have to laugh and sometimes you kind of cringe.
Ron said that after about two hours one of the cooks got done and yelled to his fellow scouts.
He says: hey, guys, it's time to eat.
And Ron said: you know, that's great, What's for dinner?
And the scout said: I don't know
What are we having for dinner.
Don't ask, Just hear it in.
Thanks, Ron. Hey, this is podcast over 171..
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag here.
Remember, if you're listening to the podcast and you're driving along in your car.
you want to avoid this problem. that I heard from Steve Fox,
who's an adult volunteer with Scout Troop 1434 in Potomac, Maryland.
He said I hooked up my iPod to the car radio system. the other day
I was listening to your podcast. Bad move,
I almost drove off the road when you led by quoting my email.
I did it again, Steve, I hope you're all right.
Bill McMahon is with Glen Falls Troop 6 and he wrote in to say
I just wanted to say thank you for the podcast and the webpage has had a real impact on my tenure as Scout Master
And, out of all the resources available to us as scouting volunteers, has had more impact on my style of leadership than any other.
My assistant Scout Master, a fellow Bob White- a little shout out to the Wood Badge world there-
Also credits Scout Master CG with helping him be a better leader.
Your common sense and boy-centered content is the fuel we use to keep the spirit of scouting burning bright here in the Adirondacks.
Thank you for all you do, Gosh. thanks, Bill.
I'm really happy to hear that people find all of this useful
And I certainly appreciate your kind words of encouragement.
A Eliah Kumar volunteers with a Scout Troop in Cheetah Baram town,
which is in the state of Tamil Nadu on the east coast of the southernmost part of the Indian Peninsula.
He wrote in to say: very, very useful resources. Thank you and keep it up
Well. thank you, I am pretty sure you're the first Indian Scouter I've heard from.
It's great to know that you're finding what we're doing useful
And we certainly appreciate hearing. Thank you very much.
Scott Gaeta is with Troop 651 in San Marcos, California,
And he said: hey, Clark, I just wanted to say: great sight and podcasts.
I really appreciate how you deliver useful and valuable information in a laidback and entertaining way.
Thanks, Scott, Thanks for being in touch and thanks for your kind words there.
Pat Lays is with Green Bay Troop 1093.
And he wrote in to say I started following you about a year ago
and I've got many useful tidbits of information I've used to provide a better program.
Thank you, Pat. Thanks for getting in touch.
Bob Case is in Corning, New York, with Troop 61.
And he wrote with this sad news a 12-year-old youth in my community
had taken their own life as a result of being a victim of bullying.
He was not a Scout, but he had many friends of Scouts in our troop,
Bob writes the unit newsletter and included this in a recent issue.
He said: what can we do as Scouters if bullying has seen? we have to act immediately.
We can't become bystanders.
We need to teach our youth not to become bystanders either,
but to be a friend and lend a helping hand to others.
Scouting teaches us to be morally straight, trustworthy and to help other people at all times.
Bullying is not acceptable and it needs to be addressed by youth adults and peers immediately.
We have to accept that our Scouts are susceptible to the peer pressure they see every day
and it's our duty that Scouting be a safe and happy environment for them.
Bob, unfortunately that's a story that gets told all too often
And while it's sad, I do appreciate you bringing it to our attention.
Bullying just has no place in Scouting.
I know that it's a topic of discussion in schools and in youth groups all over the country
and all over the world
And I think Bob's advice is spot on:
We can't be bystanders.
We have to make sure that we eliminate all forms of bullying from Scouting
and we keep Scouting a safe place for boys.
Curtis Dorbert is Scoutmaster of Troop 238 in Welcome North Carolina.
He wrote in about a recent article on ScoutmasterCGcom dealing with homesickness
and he said: you're spot on.
So many parents set up their Scout to fail with rescue plans.
It's important to coach parents on what to say should they get a call from a homesick Scout.
Cell phones are everywhere now and I've had Scouts borrow a phone from a passing Scout
so they could call home at camp.
If the parent is on board and they encourage their Scout to hang in there,
both the Scout and the parent will be proud of their accomplishments.
I also ask that if a parent gets that kind of a call
they get in touch with me as soon as possible.
Scouts that leave camp early often don't stick with Scouting.
We haven't had that issue in our Troop,
although we've had some pretty challenging situations dealing with homesickness.
I think it would be a great thing to talk about on the podcast.
Well, Curtis, your wish was my command
and in Scoutmastership, in 7 Minutes or Less, we're going to go ahead and do that.
Dave Richardson is from Western Australia
in the Waqiki First Warm Bros Sound Scout Group
and he wrote to say good day mate.
And that's how he wrote it.
It sounded like a bad Crocodile Dundee imitation,
Or at least it does when I read it.
I just finished listening to podcast 170
with the chair of the Australian Youth Council
and I was wondering if you have any objections
If I put the podcast on our website.
well, not at all, Dave. go right ahead
And I'll take the opportunity to remind everybody
that anything we produce at scoutmastercgcom
is freely offered to help support Scouting
and to be a benefit to Scouters.
If you want to post an article or a podcast
or an infographic or anything that we've produced,
you feel free to go ahead and do so.
All's we ask is that you let folks know where it came from.
That's all.
Ryan Beebe is the Training and Development Officer
for the National Rover Council in Scouts Australia,
where he works with the. We Are a Rover crew
in the Mentone Scout Group
And he wrote in to say: hey, we love the latest podcast with Chris.
I've been lucky enough to spend some time in San Diego
during my university studies
and have been hosted by a troop out there.
I've been rovering and training in Mexico and Canada
and hoping to come and visit your national jamboree this year.
Well, thanks so much, Ryan.
I'm glad that you got in touch with us,
Boy. it seems like you Australians are pretty well-traveled
and it's great to hear from you.
Arlam Ward and I made it a little difficult
for you to keep up with Scout Circle this past Sunday.
I do apologize.
We had a technical difficulty called Mother's Day.
We had to postpone our May Scout Circle
and what we're going to do is we're going to do it
on May 19th. this coming Sunday.
It'll be between 9 and 10 pm
and our plan is to talk about summer camp.
Stop by scoutscircleorg this Sunday, May 19th,
9 to 10 pm, Eastern Daylight Time,
and be part of a live presentation
where you'll be able to ask questions and things like that.
It's great fun and we look forward to having you
be a part of it.
In this podcast in Scout Mastership in 7 Minutes or less,
we're going to talk a little bit about homesickness,
just like we promised,
And then we've got an email question to answer
and a belated Mother's Day card.
Is there any other kind
For all the mothers involved in scouting out there?
So there's the podcast this time around.
Let's get started, shall we?
Scout Mastership in 7 Minutes or less.
If you're taking your scouts to summer camp this summer
and you're going to spend a week
out there away from home,
it's likely you will be dealing
with one or more homesick scouts
Now. I come from an era when homesickness
was regarded as a weakness
or something to be ashamed of,
But I want to make sure that we all understand
that preventing and treating homesickness
needs to be approached like administering first aid
for any other illness or injury.
Homesickness is not an imaginary thing.
It's not an indication of weakness
or a lack of character.
It's not a symptom of bad parenting
or bad leadership
And, thankfully, in most cases
it's pretty easy to prevent
and pretty easy to treat.
Scout leaders and parents of scouts
should consider following
a homesickness prevention plan
well before scouts are headed to camp.
There are things that scout leaders need to do
and things that parents need to do.
For scout leaders,
I would suggest making a discussion
of summer camp a regular feature
of unit meetings leading up to your stay at camp.
Talk about the program and the accommodations,
the games, the events and the daily routine
to help scouts familiarize themselves
with the experience,
Share pictures and patches
and awards from past camps.
Just talk it up real good,
and this is something that is best done
by scouts who've been to camp before right.
If it's possible,
you may even be able to arrange to have a camp staff member
visit a unit meeting
and talk to scouts about camp.
If you can arrange this,
maybe you can also get them to welcome your scouts
when they arrive at camp.
We need to very consciously work with parents
to establish a contact plan
while we're at camp.
Most experts agree that real-time contact
like phone calls or texting and email
can complicate rather than alleviate homesickness
if the stay away from home
is less than several weeks long.
Letter writing, it turns out, is a better alternative.
If you're going to sit down
and write a letter home,
it's going to require a scout to reflect
on what he's doing,
and these reflections often aid
in alleviating the anxiety
that causes homesick.
With a parent's role,
they need to make the stay at camp visible at home
well ahead of the time a scout's going to leave
to go to camp.
Mark it on the calendar
or post it on the fridge
and show your scout how long they will be away.
that can lead to a discussion of any anxiety
they may have about it.
When the scout's ready to head off for camp,
provide your scout with some pre-stamped,
pre-addressed envelopes and paper
or postcards or both,
and you might even have them practice writing
and sending a letter at home.
Sending a letter through the US mail
has become less and less common
and I don't think we should assume
that all of our scouts know how to do that.
Parents can also encourage scouts
to include a few transitional objects
or mementos while they're packing for camp,
and these could be, you know,
a family picture,
or maybe there's a stuffed animal
or any object that evokes a feeling of home.
Explain that these are symbols
that his family is safe and well
and they're excited for him to be at camp
and they look forward to hearing from them
when camp is over.
Parents should discuss any plan
for contact with their scouts
and they should both agree
to abide by that plan.
And, of course, you want to discuss
how camp will be a great opportunity
to strengthen their growing independence
and their ability to look after themselves.
It's perfectly understandable
that parents are going to be anxious
about any extended separation from their scout.
That anxiety sometimes makes the scout anxious.
Sometimes parents are anxious
that the scout will be homesick
and that kind of creates a feedback loop
that will ultimately make the scout homesick.
So if you sit down and discuss with your son
that homesickness is a pretty natural reaction
that some people have to being away
from familiar surroundings
and they shouldn't be frightened by it.
you can talk about different ways to manage it
and you can express the confidence
that your scout is going to be able to cope,
should they feel homesick,
and help him with these
specific coping strategies.
If you feel homesick,
you need to talk to your friends
and you need to talk to your scout leaders.
Don't feel like you're alone
in feeling the way that you do
or you're ashamed of saying how that you feel.
You want to keep busy and have fun
and participate in the camp program,
even if you don't feel like it at first,
and you can always write a letter
or a card home to us
and let us know how you're doing
Now. those are good coping strategies for scouts,
but there are also ways
that parents can complicate the issue
and they can make homesickness more likely.
If they indicate their own anxiety
with the pending separation.
by saying things like
we don't know what we'll do without you,
they can unwittingly undermine
their scout's ability to cope with the situation.
By no means should parents
discuss any kind of a rescue plan
Like if you don't like it,
we'll come and pick you up
or you can always call us
and we'll come and get you.
that sets a negative expectation
that's difficult for a scout to overcome.
you're basically telling them: well,
we know you're not going to like camp,
so if you get there- and that's true-
that kind of a rescue plan
undermines the experience for your scout
and it's pretty good guarantee
that you're going to get a call
and you're going to have a homesick scout.
Now, in the cell phone age,
parents and scout leaders
need to think through a parent's response
should a scout manage to contact home.
Let's remember that
real-time contact
is not a good thing
for alleviating homesickness.
they tend to make it worse,
and this information comes to me
from both from my own experience
and from several studies
that I've looked at
dealing with students and with campers
who are away from home
for different periods of time.
it turns out that up to several weeks away from home,
these real-time contacts
aggravate homesickness.
if the stay away from home
is going to be more than several weeks,
real-time contacts help
alleviate homesickness.
so what happens if a scout
somehow gets to a phone
and calls home?
a parent should be prepared to say something like
we agreed before you left on how we'd be in contact.
if this is an emergency,
you need to go to a scout leader
or another responsible adult there at camp
and I will contact the camp later today
to check in and make sure that
everything's okay.
but right now I'm going to have to go
because we agreed that we wouldn't be doing this.
it's almost always a mistake
for a parent to insist on talking
to a homesick scout
or that a scout have a cell phone at camp.
this often accentuates the anxiety
for everybody involved-
for the parents and for the scouts
and the scout leaders involved.
if a parent insists on checking in,
they should discuss precisely
how this would happen
and talk only to the adult leaders
who can give them a progress report
on how the boy is doing.
so what happens if we take all these
measures and we have the contact plan
and we've done all these things and a scout
still gets homesick? well,
that's a pretty natural thing, that's going to happen
and you should expect it to happen.
should a scout come to you
and tell you that they're homesick,
you need to respond with a great deal of patience
and caring and kindness.
being dismissive or abrupt with homesick
scouts is not going to help them
listen to what they have them say
and help them cope
again by staying busy
having fun or writing a letter home
or talking to their friends.
chiefly, it's important that we send the message
that there's no shame in being homesick.
everybody feels that way
at some point in their lives,
but we get over it and we get better.
homesickness is common.
good prevention can make it less
powerful. by familiarizing
scouts with the camp experience
and building transitions between home
and camp and establishing a contact
plan, you'll prevent the most
common causes of homesickness in scouts.
write me a letter,
send it by name
email, that is folks.
and here's an answer to one of your
emails.
we received this email from
Jeff Zook,
who is with troop 228 in Oxnard, California.
he wrote in and said:
I'm not really sure if this is a problem.
I have many adults attending our outings,
sometimes equal to the number of scouts
attending. I have been very diligent
making sure the adults stay in the
adult camp and put their hands in their pockets.
most of them do. I do have
a couple of dads that step in
because their sons, who are patrol
leaders, bring a problem to their attention
and the dads swoop in to help out.
I'm working on this,
but any suggestion would be helpful.
many of the other adults simply enjoy the outdoors
and getting away from it all
one weekend a month.
do you see this as a problem now or in the future?
well, Jeff, thanks so much for getting in touch.
what you're talking about can be a bit of a problem.
it's obviously creating
a bit of a problem for you now.
you have a couple of dads who are very concerned about
making sure that things go smoothly.
that's to be expected.
it's a very natural reaction, but it's not always
the best thing for scouts.
with that many adults getting used to
scouting in hand for scouting events,
it can become a problem
in the future. I think that
you may sit down with your troop committee
and establish some
rules for adults who are going to go camping
now. we know
that adult volunteers are a key element
of scouting, but they also have
a distinct role that
differentiates them from youth leaders.
in my experience,
scouts need the independence to run their own
program and solve their own problems,
and, this in mind,
here's what I suggest
the committee and you should get together
and draft as an understanding.
number one is that registered
volunteers have a standing invitation
to attend camping trips and meetings
and events.
attendance of adults may be limited
to preserve a workable ratio of scouts
to adults.
a maximum of one adult to three scouts
should be kind of like your rule of thumb
and just as an aside
policy statement, that is not
something that I have derived from
scouting literature. I'm saying that
one to three
maximum. in my experience
that seems to work pretty good,
not to say that one to three
is a minimum in any sense
of the word. number two: parents
who are not registered as volunteers
may attend only camping trips
and events by invitation of the patrol
leaders council or the scout master
if sufficient registered
volunteers are unavailable to support the trip.
naturally,
any activity you have in scouting
is open to observation by parents
and arrangements can be made to attend
if there's a specific concern
from a specific parent or something like
that. but the idea, I think,
of an open invitation to all parents
for every camping trip,
anytime they want to go, is going to tip
that ratio of adults
to scouts. and as you said, Jeff,
you're having some trips. you have an adult to scout
ratio of one to one, having the understanding
that parents are welcome, they can
observe any time if they need to.
but for camping trips
it's going to be by invitation of the patrol
leaders council and then you may encourage
the patrol leaders council to establish
one weekend, that is, a family camp
or, you know, a parent
and son kind of camping experience.
and then, finally, what I would have
in your little memorandum of
understanding that comes from the committee
is that all adults- volunteers
and parents are too cheerfully
and obediently follow the directions
of the scout master. now, while
we're on a scout camping trip, it's
understood that adults should be
camping in a specific section of the
campsite in their own tents,
so no adult shares a tent with their son,
and that adults will agree
to remain in the adult area throughout
their stay or to at least
remain in respectful distance from the
scout and the area and the distance
is determined by the scout master.
so other than the scout master
or those adults that he designates
will be directing
or instructing or advising or otherwise
really communicating
with the scouts. that's kind of
a quick take on what I would have
as an understanding. it gives the scout master
pretty much carte blanche to direct
and define what goes on without having
to explain themselves constantly.
I think you're right that adults do enjoy
camping once a month and getting away from it all.
that's great, but
what's going on a weekend camping trip has
nothing to do even remotely
with adults getting to
go out and have a relaxing weekend,
getting away from it all in the woods.
it's about the scouts and it's only
about the scouts. adults are
there, so scouts can go camping.
that's it. my favorite way to
explain this is to use a sports
metaphor. if parents
go to watch their son's play at some kind of
athletic contest, what are they doing?
well, they're sitting on the sidelines.
they don't call the plays. they don't run
out on the field to solve problems.
they don't surround the bench where the players
are sitting or waltz into
the dugout or talk to the players.
they don't follow their boy into the locker
room. you know. they don't ride
on the team bus, they are
spectators. now you describe
an instance of patrol leaders
asking their dads for help, and I would
suggest that you put this to a
swift and conclusive end.
their first stop is the senior patrol
leader, and if the senior patrol leader can't
help them figure things out, then the senior
patrol leader needs to come to you as
the scout master and then
you know, if you choose to, you can have
a dad help out. you're not playing the game
by the rules if
a patrol leader is just kind
of going to his dad and having him figure things
out. the sports analogy usually
works and adults do get that. you're the head
coach, the volunteers are the
assistant coaches and the scouts are the players,
and parents are spectators,
and we don't let spectators on
the field or in the dugout or in the locker
room right, they're on the
sidelines watching. so
the kind of problems
that this can cause is a hard one to see it
first. but when
you as an adult are
physically present, scouts
defer to adults
and the adult is immediately in charge.
there's really, there's just no way
to change that. don't even try. we've
conditioned our youth
to accept the
direction of adults almost
unquestioningly and
really kind of instinctively.
they spend the lion's share
of their time in school being
taught by adults. you know, when adult enters
the room everybody has to listen
to the adult. the adult is the default
leader. I always suggest that
adults need to stay away from scouts.
when the scouts are-
quote unquote- playing the game of scouting,
it's not that adults are a bad influence
or trying to consciously undermine what's going on
or have anything but the best
intentions. they just
often don't understand the dynamics
that are happening there. they have
to stay a good physical distance
away from scouts and let the scouts
themselves do the work of scouting.
I do see troops come to our summer
camp with a one to one
ratio of adults and I've
even seen a couple that come with
more adults than scouts.
I have to ask: what in the world
do I know there's no way,
even with the best behaved
adults, that the scouts have
anything like a fighting chance to exercise
much in the way of leadership or
independence or initiative if
the ratio is that high.
it takes some time and observation to
understand that it really just simply
doesn't work. Jeff, I hope that helps.
if you have a question or need
advice about a situation you have,
you can get in touch with me. you're going to find out
how to do that in just a minute.
music,
music.
a couple of weeks ago I asked three
youth candidates to find their parents
and to get them to come
to a side room in the church
where we were about to have an eager
board of honor. once we had everybody
in that little side room, I handed
each family a familiar velvet covered
box that contained the eagle award.
I told them that first
we'll have mom, practice pinning the eagle
metal on their son's left pocket.
and so three moms open the little
box and they have to fiddle around
and we're getting all the pins
and the metal loose from the
cardboard backing. and then the
moms have a chance to practice
pinning that eagle metal
onto their son's pocket flap.
and there's a little bit of nervousness
and laughter. one mom says: well,
it's not as easy as it looks,
is it? and her husband bends down
to pick up one of the pin backs
that she dropped. and I say:
no, it really isn't as easy as it looks.
that's why we have this little rehearsal:
not as easy as it looks.
well, hearing that from a mom,
that's pretty much an understatement,
isn't it? the road to that
room where those boys are standing
right now with their parents started years
ago when a little boy came
home excitedly talking about something
that his friends did called Cub Scouts.
from that point on it's just
a blur of dead
meetings and packed meetings and overnights
and trips. and then there's that tear
that gets wiped away as the little boy
stands on a stage somewhere and gets his
first badge. then he gets his
second, and his third, and his fourth and his
tenth and he brings those
badges home, and all of them gotta be
sewn somewhere, right?
and it just
as soon as you get them all sewn on one shirt-
well, it looks like he's outgrown
that shirt now and it's time to sew them
all on a new shirt, right?
and then, as he gets old enough, people
start talking about Boy Scouts. Boy Scouts,
yeah, and Boy Scouts go camping
him. but wait a minute, where are they
going camping and who's going with them?
when is this happening and what will
they be doing? wait a minute, you have to
get food for how many other Scouts
for this weekend?
at that point, it seems like months
have passed rather than years, and that
little boys grown up into this big,
gawky teenager who tramps through the
house in his muddy hiking boots,
reeking of campfire smoke,
and tosses a backpack full of clean clothes
that he never wore on the kitchen
floor before he opens the fridge.
sure, you know, every family
has some arguments and some
fears and some disappointments and doubts,
but there have also been
moments of pride and,
for mom, moments of
stark amazement. he did
what? how come? I can't get him
to do that at home? and naturally
there's been lots of love
and lots of support. somehow,
though, they made it through
somewhere along the way. that cute
little boy grew into this
big person standing
there who's now taller than
his mother and she's practicing
pinning an eagle medal onto his shirt.
I then tell them to look in the box
there's a pin for dad and we'll have
the scout practice pinning that on dad.
and there's a little more fumbling around
and a little more nervous laughter
and I tell them: we save
the best for last and I gotta tell
you there's usually a catch in my voice
when I say it- there's a pin
in there for mom too.
within the next hour or so there's a lot
of smiles, some of them are a little
nervous and there's a few tears.
but then the moment approaches
when all these families will be
standing on this stage and there's
this big, lanky kid,
who used to be a little boy,
haltingly pinning
a small token of his
appreciation- which is
really a token of all our appreciation-
on his mom
and then, to her
utter amazement and in spite of
the fact that his friends are all looking on,
he'll give her a hug
and a kiss and he'll say: thanks, mom,
from all the scouting
sons out there for all
you do. thanks, mom,
and happy mother's day.
Thanks for listening
to this edition of the
Scoutmaster Podcast.
now here's how you can keep in touch.
read the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can
subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
you can subscribe to this podcast,
The Scoutmaster Podcast, on iTunes.
you can also access
the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you get details about how to make that happen
at stitchercom.
you can experience the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
you can follow us at
scoutmasterblog on facebook,
tweet scoutmastercg on twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle,
search for us on google plus.
you can always email me.
that's right, zoom into the late 90s.
email me at
clark c-l-a-r-k-e
at scoutmastercgcom.
the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster
podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
no, you know, it's just me talking
into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun while we do.
and speaking of fun,
here's our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pel.
good luck to you and good service.
well, thank you, sir,
until next time
you.